thank you for joining us for the health
and life sciences discovery and delivery
tracks of the research summit
on day one in the health discovery track
we explored the acceleration of data and
compute driven methodologies for
diagnostic and therapeutic innovation
on day two in the health delivery track
we explored the role of research and
innovation in dismantling barriers to
healthcare access
equity in healthcare and health
resilience
and transforming the delivery of care
through new technologies and experiences
for both types of impact
for science and for society
we believe in marrying research and
implementation from the start
by working closely with partners across
the health research and innovation
ecosystem
our collective impact will come from the
deepest spirit of collaboration and
coming together
and we look forward to continuing to
engage with you all on this agenda
to learn more about microsoft research's
health discovery and delivery agenda
please visit aka dot ms msr health
we hope to see you at another microsoft
research event soon
thank you